Salut aujourd'hui on est jeudi.
Et le jeudi, en général, je parle un petit peu de ce que je veux.
Hier je vous ai expliqué que je lisais toujours tous les commentaires
Tous les commentaires.
J'y réponds un maximum.
Et alors je sais pas pourquoi,
mais depuis 3 jours,
vous me trouvez des ressemblances avec des gens !
Mais moi je connais personne.
Alors j'ai regardé sur internet
et apparemment j'aurais un air de ressemblance avec Julian MacMahon.
C'est sympa sur le principe .
À l'époque de Charmed, s'imaginer avec Alyssa Milano.
Y'a pire.
Pour être franc, je trouve pas trop que je lui ressemble en vrai.
D'autres d'entre vous, ont trouvé que je ressemblais beaucoup à Misha Collins
de Super Natural, celui qui fait Castiel, l'ange Castiel.
Mais alors pas du tout, pas du tout.
Alors expliquez moi, là je vois vraiment pas du tout un seul air.
Je sais ... je sais pas.
Vous voulez pas que je ressemble à celui qui fais Dean plutôt ?
Non ? Non bah non tellement pas.
Parce qu'à la différence des deux frères j'ai laissé mes muscles chez moi en fait
lors de mon dernier déménagement, impossible de les récupérer.
J'envoie des lettres et on me les rend pas.
Après y'a un nom qui est revenu plein plein de fois.
Au début je l'avais lu vite je croyais que c'était Romain Duris.
Et puis non c'est pas Romain, c'est Sylvain.
Et c'était pas Duris, c'est Durif.
C'est pas pareil.
Je savais pas qui c'était .
En fait je l'avais déjà vu mais je ne connaissais pas son nom.
Si on imaginait que j'avais un tout petit air de ressemblance avec Sylvain Durif ça donnerait ça :
Bon alors oui, évidemment, je suis obligé d'enfiler ma tenue de grand monarque,
de Christ cosmique.
Je ne sais pas du tout comment on met un poncho.
Comment ça se met ça?
[Voix de Sylvain Durif]
Bon alors je m'appelle Sylvain Durif
[Voix de  Sylvain Durif]
Mon nom, au plan cosmique, c'est Oriana
[Voix de Sylvain Durif]
Donc j'incarne en fait l'énergie de l'homme vert du grand monarque
Qui est annoncé par les prophéties de Nostradamus
[Voix de Sylvain Durif]
Donc ce qui est l'énergie du christ cosmique
Ce qui est terrible et presque humiliant c'est que même moi je trouve que je lui ressemble
du coup je ne me laisserai jamais pousser les cheveux en fait. Jamais.
Ce qui est vraiment chaud c'est que c'est pas comme si moi j'étais, par exemple, garagiste et lui boucher.
C'est que je suis mentaliste et il est barré...
Il est barré.
Et je me dis : peut-être qu'il y a des gens qui pensent que je suis aussi barré que lui en fait dans un sens
ça me rend ouf!
Pour parfaire l'humiliation, il cartonne sur internet.
C'est à dire que lui, il a 38 000 abonnés.
Je suis à 10 000 abonnés
donc il est 4 fois plus regardé que moi.
On devrait peut-être faire une vidéo ensemble Sylvain ?
On peut se donner rendez-vous dans une cité de lumière.
Je viens chez toi, je prends un des vaisseaux d'or de la Vierge Marie.
Si on pouvait rajouter les vaisseaux directement à l'application Uber ça m'aiderait beaucoup,
tu vois sur les applications VTC.
On pourrait savoir où ils sont exactement.
C'est de l'affection qui nous lie tout les deux.
T'es un peu mon jumeau, apparemment.
Dans une de ses vidéos, il explique qu'il doit poser le téléphone avec lequel il filme l'écran
parce qu'il doit utiliser les raccourcis clavier.
Non pas que ce soit un geek, il a pas de souris ...
Tu peux être le grand monarque, le Christ cosmique, l'énergie du géant vert ou je sais pas quoi mais
t'as pas forcément de souris... alors qu'il a une flûte par contre !
Ça n'a rien à voir avec le débat mais il a une flûte.
Il donne son numéro de téléphone comme ça, directement sur internet, évidemment.
Mais il ne faut pas lui laisser de message !
Parce qu'il ne peut pas vous rappeler, parce qu'il n'a pas de crédit non plus.
C'est-à-dire que le Christ cosmique sur ce coup là, il a plus de crédit, il a plus de souris, faudrait quand même penser à lui donner un petit coup de pouce.
Aujourd'hui je crève l'abcès, je ne suis pas le fils caché de Sylvain Durif, je ne suis pas non plus son demi frère.
Je ne vais pas me laisser pousser les cheveux.
Mais par contre, je vais peut-être me mettre à la flûte.
Si vous avez envie que je fasse une vidéo un jour avec lui
ou si vous trouvez que je ressemble VRAIMENT à Sylvain Durif,
vous pouvez laisser un petit pouce en l'air
Et le cosmos entier aura compris le message !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner et aussi que vous pouvez commenter
puisque je lis tous les commentaires et j'y réponds la majeure partie du temps.
Demain je mentaliserai quelqu'un en vidéo.
Ce sera une mentalisation active.
Samedi, masterclass, dimanche, explication de tour pour que vous bluffiez vos amis.
Portez vous bien et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain mentalvlog. Ciao !